Phoebe Cates was one of the biggest teen stars
of the 1980s.
After making her big-screen debut in the Blue
Lagoon knockoff Paradise, she starred in a
string of quintessential '80s movies, including
Fast Times at Ridgemont High, Private School,
and Gremlins.
It looked like Cates was here to stay—until
the mid-1990s, when she just kind of…vanished.
Here are the real reasons Phoebe Cates disappeared
from Hollywood.
Motherhood
Shortly after her breakthrough role in Fast
Times at Ridgemont High, Cates auditioned
for more adult roles, including Chloe in the
Baby Boomer classic The Big Chill.
She didn't get the part—it went to Meg Tilly—but
she got to meet one of the film's stars, Kevin
Kline.
They married in 1989 and now have two children
together, a son named Owen and a daughter,
Greta.
Like a lot of parents, Cates decided that
she preferred focusing on raising a family
to pursuing a full-time career outside the
home.
String Of Bad Luck
The movies Cates starred in toward the end
of her working years weren't exactly blockbusters
anyway.
Despite being the long-awaited sequel to a
very popular movie, Gremlins 2: The New Batch
took in a relatively disappointing $41 million
in 1990.
Drop Dead Fred made $13 million when it arrived
in theaters the following year, and her final
major film, the quirky 1994 comedy Princess
Caraboo, earned just $2.9 million during a
disappointing theatrical run.
Lack Of Interest
Even though she was focused on being a mom,
Cates didn't completely retire.
Her last major role was in the 2001 independent
movie The Anniversary Party.
She took the part as a favor to the director,
Jennifer Jason Leigh, one of her best friends
since the two played pals in Fast Times at
Ridgemont High.
That role is one of a small handful of projects
that Cates has deemed worthy of leaving her
kids at home to pursue.
Charity Work
Cates' son Owen has juvenile diabetes.
Since seeing its effects firsthand, Cates
and Kline devote a lot of time, effort, and
money toward fundraising efforts to find a
cure for the metabolic disease.
Among the organizations Cates supports is
the Juvenile Diabetes Research Foundation,
which puts on benefits like Rock the Cure
and the Promise Ball to raise money for research.
A New Calling
Cates lives in Manhattan's fancy Upper East
Side, which is also where she operates an
upscale boutique called Blue Tree.
The store started off selling expensive designer
toys, but has expanded to include clothing,
housewares, and specialty foods.
She told USA Today in 2006:
"I always wanted to have a general store.
If I could have had a photo booth and sold
candy, I would have."
Clearly Cates is open to the idea of selling
all kinds of things at Blue Tree.
So would she sell a mogwai, then?
"I'll give you $200.
That's $200!"
"I'm sorry, mogwai, not for sale."
Ah, well.
Probably better off.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
other ‘80s stars you’d love to see make
a comeback...